Thao CNA, Vào Rhoi Thur's, diệt dắn đoạn hoạt động tại Vinh Hông Mốc, tuyến vận tải năng lựng trong yêu của thế giới, đã khiến giá sâu và ký đốt tăng mạnh, ta đọng chực tiếp đến các định tình tại Chua.
Mọi chuyện sinh cơ quan video n đoạn Chris Nam nhận định, đây là cuộc hủng hoàn của Chua, giò có khoảng tảm ý phần trang lựng giò vận chuyển đến Chua từ Trung Đông của Hông Mốc.
Chúng khi đó, theo cơ quan thông tin năng lựng Mỹ AIA, Mỹ và Lần nước xuống phòng năng lựng giống giảm ứng động tổn thường cho bình đậm hình công.
Về phí trò á, các đứa nhận động nhập hơn một đủ lựng giò và khoảng 2 phần bài là được tự trung đông.
Nhưng bạn nhập tới 7000 vận trăm dầu, và miệm một phần trăm lựng được còn hành Quốc phục thuộc và khoảng 7000 vận trăm dầu và 2000 vận trăm lựng được.
Phí lý pén xí nhập tới 7000 vận trăm dầu thuộc trung đông.
Thứ chuyển giả khai nhóm Lawrence Adissan từ Trung R.C. Cạnh báo giá năng lộng tăng kéo theo chí phi vận tải sản xuất và lãng phát leo thang, gây ám lựng lựng lên tăng trường.
Mọi giá về giảm đoạn tại Hôm Note còn nành hồn lý vận chuyển phần báo và lương thật làm giá thang dù sau và kinh tế.
Một dù gió đàn truy khăn đưa lòng của người cơ i ra nghe tham đất của tuyến các năng lộ và tham khoảng dự biển tải thịn và tự.
Điều này có thể gây giám đoạn đi tù nét của tế, đã biệt là thang và đồng tài chính giữa truộng và truộng và truộng.
Điều xuất gần kéo xai, chua có thể tự tụi bởi mặt bởi bởi bởi bởi bởi bởi bài chính, đếp gái chuối cùng ở lưỡng và ám lực làm phát giá thang chí dây dòng.